[Music]
welcome to episode 44 of the game spot
after dark odd cast game spots official
chill hike via podcast
I am the water stains going by Michael
hi yo what up
Jordan remain hello and Alessandro
filari hey how's it going everyone doing
the best we can in these times to the
appropriate response is like a really
deep inhale and then a really long
exhale I think that captures every kind
of range of emotion necessary for now so
we usually have a segment on the podcast
if anyone is nutria called
the Chris from Dayton Ohio segment now
it's usually for newcomers Alessandro
your visitor first time appearing on
this podcast so you'll have to do this
Jordan are we've had been in this
podcast but you know I don't think the
crystal Dayton Ohio segment existed ever
say I think the last time I was on the
podcast number was still in the single
digits so yeah we'll start with them
Jordan and Chris from Dayton Ohio second
segment is effectively a summation of
who you are what you do and what you
like so let us know what you're into
woof
well I am the one of the associate
editors on the news team at GameSpot so
you might not necessarily see me around
all that often I'm kind of like mix into
the normal news coverage but if you pay
attention to the anime and apex legend
stuff on the website those are kind of
like my beats and whenever something
Xbox related comes up I usually touch it
in some capacity because I'm an Xbox boy
I have a Playstation I have a switch but
I am one of those like final diehards in
the office who still plays most of their
games on xbox and yeah that's I I think
soon that's everything that you're
looking for like like how like how much
information we talking like life story
do you want like when I was what would
you say I your are your favorite games
like top three favorite games of all
time top three favorite games would be
titanfall 2 Mass Effect 2 and got one
more men to go let's just complete let's
complete the pattern here Assassin's
Creed 2 all twos - Wow sweet sequels
isandro who are you what do you do here
what do you like what your favorite
three favorite games of all time cool hi
I'm Alessandra I like to more said this
is my first time being on I'm an editor
a GameSpot I basically do a little bit
of everything I used to do a lot of
traveling before we you know all went
into quarantine I'm basically the guy
that helps you know sort of coordinate
upcoming opportunities and you know sort
of I I basically keep everyone in the
loop for what's happening or what will
happen so yeah I mean I basically write
features I've occasionally write news um
I've been in the industry for about nine
years this year actually and actually a
few days ago was my third year at
GameSpot so ya know it's a it's been a
it's been an interesting ride yeah but
yeah top three games unless I missed it
a question there no no no yeah the
original Devil May Cry final fantasy 12
and you know uh Street Fighter 3 third
strike nice laughs three solid games but
that final fantasy 12 I did not know
that about you even a whole new light I
mean it's a great final fantasy game
honestly and deserves more
read it like that it actually got I'm
actually glad that zodiac age you know
edition came out because I think more
people were sort of giving it its due so
yeah it's it's it's easily the best
always game ever created that's that's
fair if you haven't played twelve zodiac
a jounce which is pretty much essential
it's amazing it's got fast forward more
as marginal yes rajee's need fast
forward they also put an update where
you can reset your classes which was
yeah which is a big thing so yeah I'm
actually interested in doing like a
revisit on my game so yeah I've got them
like Paul the way for it and it's
fantastic alright speaking of what we're
playing hi I'm Michael I am what you
been billion I am reporting in on the
latest games to hit video game worlds so
first thing I'll probably talk about is
Valerie I'm in the process of reviewing
valor n't it just launched on Tuesday
and I I was I played a lot of the betas
and it was a pretty known quantity at
that point and not much has changed like
the core game is still pretty much what
you play in the beta things have been
refined obviously the the bug fixes the
tweaks the like the the patch notes log
is huge and a lot of smaller things to
kind of round out the game but I mean I
feel pretty much the same way as I did
in the beta there's a new map that is
frequently put into the rotation and
it's it's pretty much your standard like
csgo style map overall valor n't is very
much like your csgo style game with hero
powers and stuff like that and that
that's all to say that it's very good
like the thing about valor n't is that
yes it's emulating the CS formula very
much with very heavy overwatch tones but
the thing I like about it is that it
executes sit extremely well it's like
really tight and that's not an easy
thing to pull off because it's yes at
his core is a very precise game in terms
of balance and how you play and how
you're supposed to play the game to
succeed is a very you know it's it's
very
specific way to play those styles of
games and Valerie does it really well
I'm not gonna say it like breaks new
ground or anything because it is very
much borrowing from three separate games
it's just a really well-done mishmash of
those things but I'm gonna obviously I'm
gonna be giving it a lot more time come
with through strategies try out all the
new all the different agents as the
column not heroes agents because I
mainly play like three different ones
but there's a overall think 11 right now
and that's a lot of work before I have
final thoughts but I'm working on
putting up a review in progress maybe by
the time this podcast goes up or a
little bit later but it's definitely I'm
trying to hit this weekend to have a
review in progress so yeah I'm you know
hit me up if you want to know about
valor in curious about at all it's too
hard for me I can't play yeah I mean
like I I love CS I played it's probably
still the game I put the most amount of
hours into so I played a veteran at beta
and I really enjoyed what I played it
was part of it I found like required a
little more polish if you know what I
mean like some of the sound effects some
of the visual kind of stuff like
whenever an enemy uses like that fog
type ability yeah as an area it just
looks like someone's dumped like him a
turd on the map it's spinning yeah
someone's dumped it and then stirring it
like that's that's the one thing I'll
say about valor and is that its
presentation is severely lacking like
you go from overwatch to valor and from
apex to like any other service style
shooter that has hero types in them
Valerie is severely lacking like I go
into apex I'm like excited about the
character select screen sit like you
yeah exactly like you buy animations
intro animation characters and your
title cards and their poses and all that
stuff and that's that's a very exciting
part like well I can't wait to like deck
out Krypto unlike the dopest kpop jacket
like duotone jackets and [ __ ] like that
that's less exciting Valerie's gotten
the characters it's it's weird I feel
like it's like yes it has a diverse
roster but their personalities are so
like not bear that it kind of doesn't
matter in a way and that's unfortunate
but I am you know these games are in the
state right now that's how I feel but of
course these games are always evolving
but yeah like what Sam was saying about
like the graphical presentation like
yeah this is made to be a low spec game
that can play on old computers but even
if you cranked everything up to high
settings like it doesn't look all that
different and it's it looks bland and a
bits like rough but it works is what
I'll say yeah
functional if not very very functional
but uh that's well speaking of dated
games that look dated also Phantasy Star
Online 2 you know I know PS L 2 is is
fun it's it's good I'm also in the
process of reviewing that that's a
little bit up in the air in terms of
timing for that I need to talk to Callie
about that residents like your third
review like back-to-back or something
like that it's like fourth or fifth
I love reviewing games man but yeah pso2
is it's gonna it is messy that game is
very messy like old it's old but it's
like it the the quality of life and UI
stuff has not changed at all like it's
been around for ten years and that [ __ ]
has not been touched for ten years see
you go into the game you're like what
though what am I supposed to click on
how do i click on it how do I access
that menu what is this quest how do I
can't join a party until before I take a
quest and I can't go like there's so
many things about pso2 that should that
you would expect to be refined in a game
that comes on 2020 but this being like
props to it to being very true to what
it was in 2010 they're just like eight
years localized version of what that was
it's fun though I'll say that much
but I I think I think pso2 is if
anything a fantastic example or like a a
kind of something to have there that
shows you how far a memos have come like
you if you want to see like you know
that's a good way to do it look at play
that game and then play literally any
modern yeah the facts but yeah it's
still fun at its core but it's it's
dated in so many ways but there is like
this there's this like Dreamcast era
Sega charm to it I think a lot of it has
to do with the like the presentation
style and like character models the way
the environments look feel like very
high-rez detailed version of a Dreamcast
era game I mean that's also cuz like
Phantasy Star Online one is also of that
time so that makes sense there are a lot
of cool things around the edges but I I
think I need to spend a lot more time in
PSO to to kind of figure that out more
so than balint at this point so I'm
gonna be doing that all through the
weekend and there's another MMO that I'm
gonna be playing over the weekend for
play for all that I I mean I'm not gonna
talk about just cuz you know that stuff
is still and it works but man I got my I
got a lot for your games man bless you
bless you for making the attempt Ryan
Balor an FF no puns for you bro Jordan
what you've been playing all doing I'm
always playing apex I'm I'm literally
never stopping playing apex I think like
there was a brief period in season 1
where I stopped playing because there
was just no new content coming out but
about a week before season 2 started in
July of last year I basically just made
sure that I played like an hour to every
single day and that's that's my life I
just I just play apex legends and I keep
bugging you Tam and Chris to write about
and I mean I can the numbers man yes so
much it's like one of the most proudly
diverse games ever like going back to
your whole like character thing how a
lot of hero shooters are kind of iffy
and stuff like that apex Legends has
such good heroes and such a diverse
roster of them like how many games out
there can you just point to that have a
roster like this outside of like
overwatch because overwatch did it first
if it feels very natural to me like I
think ice like we said that in the 2019
game of the year discussions is that
like yeah it's like I've gibraltars my
boy cryptos my boy you know as a lot of
women of color included in there too but
it feels natural like oh [ __ ] like y'all
are doing it right I think this is some
conversations around Lobos design though
I think a lot of uh Latin ex folks are
chiming in on the like the office
authenticity but also the like we see a
lot of the like that music we've see
we've seen ourselves in this way many
times in media before like it's it's I
know it's not like a stereotypical
example of the reporters but it's it has
portrayed Puerto Rican woman like this a
lot it says a lot that you can point out
at least one other character who is
pretty much the same like when whenever
when she showed up pretty much everyone
who plays overwatch when Sombra and
that's that's a that's kind of a problem
yeah and also speaking of valor ensue
just added a new character for the hot
her name is Raina and lady yeah and I
was like that's that's Sombra but like
they're they're continually playing into
this like this sort of criminal esque
Latino woman and I and it's like alright
we've we've been down this road before
we can we can be a little bit more
creative in how we rep
though I represent latina women and
games but yeah
apex go off and then and then you're
playing rocket League I am i I feel
really bad because Peter was always
trying to get me to play rocket League
with him and Rob like before he left and
sometimes I would play and sometimes we
like no I I want to play more apex and I
have no idea why but like two weeks ago
I was just thinking you know rocket
League is pretty fun I should I should
try playing that game again and I've
just been playing it for like a good
hour like every single day I'm like I'm
back in rocket League now III took a
year and a half break and now I'm just
back in it for whatever reason and what
a stupidly simple game that is so
addictive to play I need to get back
into it
played like we played in the tournament
me Lucy and Dave Tara in in the UK and
then that was the last time I played it
so much energy into getting good for a
tournament and then once I was done I
was like no five years running man
rocket leagues been out there for about
five years at this point
Jordan's out there I think I'm just like
Michael you're telling me all the time I
gotta play persona Jakes all the time
telling me that I got to play Witcher 3
and I'm just I need a break from those
really long story driven games like I I
just know like I just want the
multiplayer games or like I play a match
and it's just done in like 5 to 10
minutes I'm like cool that was awesome
gonna do that like 1 or 2 more times
then I'm done for the day like I can't
do that if I play persona 5 loyal you
see you said that what did you say it's
like oh you don't have or you need to
take a break from playing long story
driven games bro you need to just do it
it's rewarding and you know I have it
it's on my ps4 it's downloaded I bought
it it's there I just
no I feel you though like the having
those palate cleanser type games ever
since I got a Project Diva Hatsune Miku
on switch I just look at my switch and I
pick it up and like I'm gonna play a
couple songs then play five songs then
played ten songs and played 20 songs and
I'm like wow and now I don't have time
to play the game that I was supposed to
be playing so I I understand man yeah
Alessandra what you currently playing
yeah I've actually gone for a revisit to
Assassin's Creed origins oh my god I
actually reviewed the game like what
almost three years ago now and as my
first time coming back to it I've been
playing on PC and you know it's I feel
like I'm I think I feel like I like the
game a lot more now than I did before my
god
mostly because just just how much like
the setting itself is just just so
fantastic and I still think it's one of
the best like achievements of the series
Assassin's Creed like you know just a
there's so much level of detail and
craft went into it and you know I'm just
like really blown away still even now
like three years later I'm still blown
away by that setting and you know I
still feel a little weird about how
funky like the action RPG elements are
in a game especially considering you
can't like you know is to kill someone
with the assassin hidden blade like a
beginning once you get it so you know
I'm still sort of wrestling with it in
some cases but you know I I mean that
setting man is just so so good man well
I'll friend Jordan might have a little
happy telling you people just get the
second DLC and you can like I remember
Jordan mentioning and I'm like ooh I got
it I gotta do this cuz like this is just
sort of like becoming untenable like you
know just trying to you know basically
do the same like sort of actions you
would do in other Assassin's Creed games
but you know you sort of like hit the
wall of like well you're your character
doesn't have this particular stat or you
don't have this particular item or
equipment so I'm like all right like I'm
just looking forward to that moment
where I can actually do you know
the DLC missions and sort of like dis
kick to that you know to get that stuff
out of the way so yeah are you are you
finding yourself like consistently
stopping and taking screenshots because
I also started like a lot of people
started assess screen origins again and
I put a lot of times to the game just
recently and a lot of that time is spent
taking screenshots I actually did that
when I was reviewing so much like you
know like like taking screenshots using
that photo mode and like uh it's I mean
just even now on PC it looks even better
than it did like before so just I like
just climbing up and just finding like a
good spot for me like to sort of Kirk
himself on sort of like I can zoom out
the camera and just get a good angle
like it's great like you know just again
that setting is just so fantastic I also
byuk is such a great kid bias I can I
are they are they are so they may they
be smashing all the time like you know
like their dynamic is it feels a genuine
it in a way that like because every time
you come to her and you're like okay
like we got to do this mission we got
fascinate this this one fool and then
they're like alright goodbye my love and
then it's like okay we'll smash real
quick yeah it's like it's like good yeah
yeah okay like they're like Ryder dive
with each other really like when I think
of like good video game cumple couple
like I it's by again my god
if you hopefully so if things go our way
and we'll have the voices of why can I
ask they were originally supposed to be
tomorrow but due to some circumstances
we've had to shift it and we're
currently rearranging so fingers crossed
we'll have them involved but yeah you're
also playing Alessandro Streets of Rage
for I am yeah just I've beaten the game
like five times or I'm just like I'm
just taking control of each character
like you know it the game really isn't
that long so it's not like too much of
like a time sync but I mean it's I mean
the game just feels so good like you
know I mean they the the guys making it
looser cube and a guard crush like they
just did a great job of not only
respecting
the original games like particularly
Streets of Rage to which a game is sort
of like short frame but modeled after
and on a mechanical level but also just
the being insane like sort of art style
like you know I know people are a little
bummed out like it's not you know sort
of the sprite work like you know Genesis
style sprite work but it is I mean just
the game just has so much personality to
and like my one my favorite levels in
the game is where you sort of like fight
through like an art gallery that's like
no sort of like half destroyed and like
you know you see like you know really
vivid like pop art sort of like coming
from the background like you know it's
and like a lot of me on my sort of
illuminating the battles and stuff and
it's it's a really cool game like you
know I'm it's easily like one of my top
10 favorites of this year so yeah I was
like every time we reap reviewed it like
a couple times throughout its before
it's released and every time we've we
played it I like packs and stuff we're
all like damn that was that's pretty
good yeah it's pretty good damn good
yeah we actually got to play with the
developers at PAX at PAX East then we
did like four player co-op and there's
that moment we almost got like like a
hundred hits I was like I was telling
everyone get 200 200 we're capturing a
lot of fun just and I'm glad I'm so glad
before the final game turned out to be
just just amazing and then gentlemen
three right yeah I'm playing this game
called Borderlands 3 and all sound
rollers played like a hundred times more
than the coordinates back in the day
when we still had desks and offices I'd
see him playing I'm just like I was like
why why you do now we can't give him
[ __ ] though because he's at home playing
it according to epic games like client I
played up to 12 days just really quickly
just really quickly I just want to say
that you know I I admit the story is not
great
I think it has some really weird like
choices in humor I can say it it's
probably but it is clearly the family
guy of video games as far as like you
know as far as like you know what it
tries to do with pop culture and like
you know trying to make some you know
cute jokes with like you know two movies
or whatever but the shooting and the
loot drop loot drive is just it's great
like that's why I keep coming back to it
it's they agree but like what what are
you doing like what content are you
playing why do you just write it with
there's four characters you know I eat I
have to get them all to like a top level
so I can you know try to get as much
loot as I can so I've already maxed out
with the flack who's the last character
so every other character is already
maxed level at this point but except
lack so well I mean you know you do you
man is as long as it makes you happy I
am doing me I'm playing twelve twelve
days worth of 188 hours so I have been
playing loads of royal royal royal
fantastic game and takes a game that was
exceptional and pretty much makes it
perfect I think absolutely loving it and
then I'm rewatching Avatar The Last
Airbender because you know it's also
perfect it's perfect as well yeah and I
I've seen that show many times and I
feel like I've gone and recommended it
into enough people now that I'm like I
should I should put my money where my
mouth is and also watch it again so I
mean my acid he watch it like she can
watch it last I spoke to her is watching
it I think once Lucy returns she'll talk
about as well because she's currently
watching it I think there's the plan to
do a spoiler cast with me
you Lucia and just you know Kelly Kelly
Kelly Kelly and Kelly on first ones like
a look this is perfect perfect
we'll do that yeah it is fantastic
beyond that I've been mainly focusing on
play for all which leads us into the
kind of topics of discussion for this
week
a lot of stuff has happened over the
last week in terms of gaming news
there's been events that have come and
gone the biggest one being the
PlayStation 5 reveal event which was set
for Thursday
that's right yeah Thursday and it's now
been cancelled
I think it's not as important to talk
about in the minutiae of the events that
are canceled more than why it was
canceled so I think it's a good
opportunity to have that discussion and
reflect upon that and obviously we're
talking about the black lives matter
movement and you know there was the
awful events around the brutality
towards doors Floyd and the resulting
movement that has come out has you know
for want of a better phrase swept the
nation but yeah so the events in gaming
or rightly so stepping aside for those
discussions to happen and so PlayStation
5 reveal event has been you know kind of
put on the back burner I think it feels
like I need to insert a question in here
to create a discussion and the only
question you can really ask is a bad
question which is do you think that was
the right decision that's not the
question I want to ask but I just want
to throw it to you guys and let you say
your piece and what's happening and how
you feel about it and why you think it's
important because there might be some
people who are listening to this that we
hope and we know that the people that
listen to this or podcast are people
that support and have open minds and are
very welcoming and open hearts to this
stuff but there might be a person who
doesn't understand what's going on so
for those people you know say your
pieces and and you know how do you feel
about this what's going on and the fact
that these companies are being vocal
what's it like to finally see a lot of
these companies step out and be like
yeah this is important to us well I mean
it's it's
it's basically just like a culmination
of the perfect storm you know like all
of these feelings and emotions like it's
not like all of a sudden let's care
about black lives matter like there have
been protests there have been people
speaking out about it there have been
people of color and specifically black
people talking about this in our
industry and other industries for years
and years long before me like I'm the
youngest one here I'm 26 like my my rage
hasn't like Fester to like the quiet
anger yet I'm not old enough yet for
that to have happened but just given the
fact that something like this could have
happened while everyone stuck at home
because of Koba 19 while Trump is
president while it's the summer so it's
really like hot it's like all of these
things have kind of like boiled together
to create this like boiling point to the
extent that people like okay we need to
take stock and really look at this and I
would have liked if we could have like
just taken stock I mean like you know we
should actually talk about these issues
and come up with solutions without
another black person being shot by a
police officer but here we are the
conversation is happening again it's a
good conversation to have I feel like
there isn't easy like answer to whether
or not this was a good step to take I
hope that the people listening to this
kind of agreed that this was a good step
to take but at the very least like the
conversation is happening and it's a
conversation that we've had a dozen
times before and honestly I'm just
worried that it's going to be a
conversation that we're gonna have
dozens of times in the future but I hope
I'm wrong if I made yeah just a common
sentiment I saw was that a lot of people
were sort of looking forward to event as
a sort of like a break from like a lot
of what's been happening just say even
before this like you know what happened
with a George Flinn George Floyd I'm
just you know I'm on one end I I can
understand that sort of mindset but at
the same time this isn't that I mean
this isn't the time for
escapism you know I mean this is a time
where we everyone needs to listen you
know to people that really need to be
heard and you know I I do appreciate
that um that a Playstation
you know Sony decided that this this
event wasn't the right time it wasn't
the right time to do this event and uh
but at the same time I I do feel like
for the audience in general I do feel
like it's important for you know as
Jordan said just you know listen to the
people listen to you know the
communities like the people that have
been trying to be heard you know just
trying to you know have their voice you
know in the community as well so I'm on
one and that's why I really appreciate
you know just the fact that we're just
last few days we're trying to you know
sort of prop up people like you know
within our you know the games industry
like you know can be the writers of
color content creators of color like you
know Cleve Adams from a spawn on me and
you know blessing from kind of funny
who's just been fantastic it's been
really great seeing him sort of blow up
and like you know really you know make a
name for himself and even you Jordan I
mean your your you really you know just
you've been here for two years I mean
you've you've been um just a fantastic
like addition to the team and you know
just uh I think it's important for
people to recognize that you know there
are people of you know a certain
perspective that you know that have a
voice and you know that perspective is
needed and that perspective is necessary
and that that's something that people
need to you know sort of listen more to
so yeah that's kind of wow that's kind
of what I've been feeling the last few
days if that makes sense yeah yeah I
mean when Tam and I kicked off the play
for all event on Monday and we had this
dream where we we got a really sudden
shift towards to support black lives
matter with the play for all event which
I'm more than happy that we're doing
like like yo word let's let like let's
do this this is this is like
invigorating for for us to make that
move for donations and all that and it
was it was a little weird though cuz
like I was I was actually down here in
Oakland when I got like the slack
message saying a word
we want to have you on talk about these
talk about these issues live on air and
I'm like yes I I I think I can
articulate that reason with the audience
that you know why we are making the
shift and why it makes sense you know
why we should partake in the fight for
black justice and you know and we say
this many times like Sam and I are non
black people of color so that's an
important perspective to internalize for
us because you know we like the term
ally should be we shouldn't need to say
that we should already be allies by
default but we need to turn that into
like okay yes we agree that black
justice is the thing that needs to be
fought for and but we need to turn that
into action so there's a lot of ways of
support you know monetarily with bail
funds for people who are protesting
giving to black lives matter because
that's an actual organized movement and
that's you know you'll see a lot of like
bad actors co-opting that black lives
matter as like oh it's just like a bunch
of it's not organized it's just people
trying to cause chaos like nah it's an
organized movement and they're making
changes and I say this all time to is
that like you know if used like all like
I will not even say it but all lives
won't matter until black lives matter
everyone's been making like a lot of
good people have been making the analogy
is that like you know if you go to a
doctor and you have a broken bone
you know doctors not gonna look at all
your bones you gonna look at the one
that that needs attention that's one
that's hurting like yes of course all of
your bones matter yes that is a given no
one needs to say that pay attention to
the one that is hurting and support like
make sure that you make things right
there so that's that's how people should
feel about black lives matter I know the
after dark audience is they're very good
people and like they're very receptive
to us but I just want to make sure that
the folks who do listen to afterguard
understand one where we stand of course
but also to if there have if they have
any hasn't
see in supporting black lives matter and
the protests that have happened in 50
states when was the last time that
something happened in all 50 states at
one time globally - you see it all
around the globe is that people are
protesting taking to the streets and
there's there's a reason why that's
happening and I hope that everyone who
listens to this podcast can get behind
that
you know we're obviously doing a
fundraiser but and we're trying to use
our platform to draw attention and
that's that's really important and I
hope that you know it's it doesn't stop
at donations it you know internalized
what you're being what's what you're
learning and take that and continue that
and for us like you know obviously like
white people y'all need to keep y'all
folks in check and let let let them know
like what your role is in this like this
isn't black people shouldn't have to be
fighting on their own for this and then
like even like for people of color like
listen Filipino older Filipinos could be
racist is fun I'm gonna keep it real
with you like an older generation has
internalized colonialism in a big way
and it's a big problem and I think we
need to realize that you know people of
color can be racist towards black people
too and it's a reality we need to face
and for us who who are obviously like
want to fight against that we need take
that into our own communities like we
need to we need to communicate that to
our own people as well to get them on
boards to change their minds to make
them realize that this is something that
they should be fighting for - and not to
be racist as [ __ ] like that's like it's
it's easy but it's very hard to get
through to some people and like I need
to do that like I I text my friends I'm
having conversations like my mom and my
my other parents about this lake cuz I
got a text is like why you down in the
protest like because like the system
[ __ ] we need to do it's like oh why why
you like why are you pressing me on this
like yeah I don't know it hurts it hurts
dude like I mean like
like what's there yeah there's a there's
a generation note it's the same with him
like not pakistani yeah pakistani and
like muslim communities as well where
it's like because you're not the target
you did they don't feel a lot of people
may not feel the need to get involved
and i'm sure there's a lot of listeners
that have situations that are similar
with family members or friends and often
it just takes you to remind them of the
smaller that the discrimination that
they have might have had or their
parents might have spoken about in their
lives that is a fraction of what is
happening to black people right now like
muslims for example have gone through
some stuff themselves and i found it
powerful in speaking to my friends and
family just reminding them of how they
felt in a moment when someone was
screaming terrorist at them as they walk
down the street in the way that i have
had that pain that you felt imagine if
that wasn't just a thing that you could
walk away from and they stuck with you
for maybe a few days imagine if that
moment escalated every single time and
your life was on the line and that's
that's that's kind of what has helped
break through to some people and it's
important for even if you're not colored
to remember that those moments of danger
that you feel may have felt in your life
you know you know the the real ones they
pop up in your mind and they horrify you
like when you remember those
circumstances in the context around it
they can make you feel like in trouble
again imagine if that was your every
single day if that was your moment the
moment you walk to the moment you slept
every single day you were you had to
prepare yourself to expect one of those
every day that's no way to live man
and you you owe it to yourself and you
owe it to the people around you to stand
up and say something and yeah it's it's
just essential it's not a thing that you
should be thinking about doing you just
need to do and that's meant the big
reason why we introduced not introduced
but we thought it was necessary to have
the black lives matter
kind of fundraiser element to play for
all it was something that came together
very very quickly but it was not a
discussion it wasn't whether we should
do this it was how can we do this as
quickly as possible and the result is
what you're getting now it's not as
elegant as everything as we would
perhaps want it to be we're still kind
of pivoting on things were introducing
you know we saw it with one donation
method and then we had to kind of fold
in another one on top so we could
actually track the thing the money is
still all going to black lives matter
and now we can track it so and you know
the articles that are coming together
very last minute like Jordan bless him
he worked until like 9:00 p.m. to to
kind of get that aqua because then I do
and I got a do Tam I do a yeah I mean
like I was I was there with you trying
to make sure I was like please I'm sorry
I like I felt bad because it was on a
day that we told everyone don't write
don't work you're not doing anything all
we're going to do today is amplify Black
Voices and that's what we try to do but
in order to do that the day before we
had to prepare an article to show that
just so show people that we're going to
do that you give people something to
read and Jordan appointment and then the
follow-up our call where we've been
inviting people to reach out to us on
Twitter and suggest names of black
creators and voices that we could
highlight and then we put them all in a
separate article that's on site as well
and you should seek it out and one of
those people watch their streams they
all have valuable unique perspectives
but that came together very not last
minute but in a rush but that's that's
kind of what playful role has been and
it is what it's needed to be and we're
going to continue to push that over the
coming six weeks and beyond I think the
one thing that's important to note is
like guess what as a team is diverse I
think you guys feel the same way where
this matters to every single one of us
and we will continue to push on this and
and highlight how important it is for us
to amplify these black voices and
support black voices and members of the
community and black people as a whole
yeah especially when it when it comes to
like black people in the industry like
obviously our audience is gonna be
gravitating towards gaming and there are
a lot of black voices in gaming who have
been doing this for a very long time and
I've been following them because I mean
and because they're they're they're
great creators but they don't like
having my timeline full with all these
perspectives overtime gives you
perspective you learn from just like
simply following on the work that's like
the bare minimum you can do is like
listen listen to them it might like not
everything is going to be about race or
LGBTQ issues or things like that but
just their perspective on anything else
on games like death stranding or on apex
like also Andrew and Jordan do like just
having listening to their perspective
seeing it and normalizing that if you
haven't already is like that's a step
everyone should be taking and that's
kind of like why I think it's valuable
that like okay yeah I follow them but I
need to let other folks know that y'all
should be following them too and yeah
over time it's very much like taught me
a lot and I talked to Khalif Adams about
that too and I muscle on spawning me
which you all should be following as
well that you know it's very important
to diversify your your your timeline and
people you follow especially like black
women in in gaming like you got to seek
them out too for all sorts of reasons
but you will you'll learn a lot and get
like valuable perspective on games but
you got to make sure that you like as a
caveat like make sure that you reach out
to these diverse voices in the right way
there's a very unfortunate trend and I
can really only speak to the gaming
industry because it's the one that I
know the best but I'm sure that it
extends to others to profit off of the
pain of minorities especially people of
color
especially woman where if you have a
game that handles race or has a game
that handles gender or anything that
could be considered a minority to let
someone of color or a woman or another
minority to cover this game for them to
provide their perspective kind of
knowing that the article that they will
write though will be insightful will
also be the type of article that like
the Internet being the Internet is going
to jump on and is going to get mad
clicks and be very popular it's easy to
see how you can use someone's diversity
to benefit yourself and kind of still
pat yourself on the back by saying like
oh I did something good I allowed this
black voice to speak out about this
black person in the video game and
that's really not the right way to go
about it the I always tell people like
it's much less about diversity as it
isn't about inclusivity like that's one
of the things I appreciate most about
games what like are there more ways that
we could improve our diversity quota
absolutely but it is also a site that I
joined and it's not like on the very
first day Tam and Chris like sat down
with me or like okay Jordan how many
like black video games do you want to
write about like they didn't just
immediately jump on that for me to cover
it's like cover whatever you want and if
a story presents itself that ties into
who you are will support you when you
want to pitch it and critique it and
offer a feedback and we'll work through
it and then the article will come out
and that's a good way to handle that
situation that only comes if you have a
lot of people who are diverse like on
your staff like one of the things that
I've kind of like seen that annoys me
like just a little bit is the aspect
that when giant huge triple-a games come
out like the go-to they they only get
like one or two codes given to each
outlet it's always been this way it will
probably continue to always be this way
and they do I assume they do it this way
just to make sure that the game doesn't
or anything like that but by only one or
two codes going out to people when it's
giant Triple A games Assassin's Creed
Call of Duty last of a cyberpunk usually
the people who are going to review those
games are the reviews editor the
managing editor or editor-in-chief the
people that the site trust the most to
handle those giant games and the fact
that it is most of those people across
our industry are white like black people
don't get very high up in the grand
scheme of things when it comes to these
websites so you have to pull in these
diverse voices but then you have to keep
them around long enough and promote them
long enough so that when a giant game
like Last of Us part 2 or cyberpunk 2077
comes around they're in a position to
then analyze that game and possibly get
something out of it that their white
counterparts might not am I saying like
oh there's every black person should
have reviewed last was like no obviously
not like that's not what I'm saying at
all I'm just saying like just looking at
Twitter you can see that a majority of
the people reviewing that game are white
so a majority of the reviews will be
from a white perspective which maybe
won't matter
maybe Last of Us part 2 doesn't look at
race in any conceivable way shape or
form but it is something to at least
consider that are we basically setting
ourselves up for failure if we just have
the same core group of people reviewing
the same games over and over and over
again and you have you have to attract
those voices and first you have to
promote them up and give them a chance
if you want things to change sure and uh
you know just um one thing that you know
I just really think is important is that
a you know a lot of these uh you know
article I look up features about the
black perspective you know they get they
tend to you know become more relevant
with age like I noticed that you know
from us gamer from Jeffrey Russo about
black journalists in the games industry
like a you know that's especially
relevant right now like just thinking
about it like you know and especially
seeing like you know just especially
over the last few days you know how many
just you know the wealth of you know
sort of black perspective you there is
within our industry and like you know
amount of writers and content creators
there are and you know it is you know
it's especially frustrating to see that
you know they haven't been given that
opportunity even though they have the
talent they have the following they have
their own personal following and you
know but it's like you know again it's
just a lot of ways that just focuses on
like I guess our our system where you
know the big fish tend to get a lot of
the attention or whatever but um but
even like you know for us like I can I
feel like I can speak for us like oh we
we do think about like you know articles
like this you know focusing on the black
perspective you know other you know can
groups from minority groups or you know
like I remember are one of our last
features beings and what in the office
like we were pitching around ideas you
know it wasn't necessarily themed around
you know obviously Black History Month
or whatever it was just in the now we
were thinking about our own perspectives
now like you know it was like you know
just actually an article I thought about
link and I was really trying to get
going but just didn't work out where
idea of reasons was you know what it
means for a video game to have a strong
black lead and you know and I touched a
bit on that like in the past with a far
cry article which got reprimanded and
says and like sometimes there's an
article that just sort of picks up maybe
it gets a lot of attention you know
maybe in some ways you may not expect
but you know I still feel strongly about
that article because it was my
experience and it was an experience that
maybe a lot of people really you know so
wouldn't necessarily think of like when
they play a big-budget game like that
you know that's something I think of and
I'm sure something a lot of people would
think of as well like you know what is
what's it like playing far cry 5 as a
black character and you know that that
made me feel very anxious and honestly
after just seeing how things went last
two years I feel like I was on the money
with that article but you know it was
just it's it's a trip like you know just
seeing how things have turned out and
you know I do feel like one of the
greatest things about videogames not
only the fact that you know obviously
it's
you know it's about bringing people
together but you know the the the level
of escapism it can offer but at the same
time you know as I said earlier it's
important just to listen you know to you
know different perspectives on the
xscape ism that we sort of like dive
into like you know because I remember
with cyberpunk like people were showed
concerns about how they portray people
of color in that game and you know I I
preview the game and I felt that felt
the same way to like you know I'd is
this like you know is it doing the right
thing like I understand it's an
extrapolation of our current times but
you know I mean obviously things aren't
you know things it's important to have
like a different perspective and the
making of the games as well and you know
I I wish you know developers would keep
that in mind but you know I feel like
the only way to do that is to have more
people of color you know women
especially more women especially you
know to be able to have their
experiences with the games that we spend
so much time with you know heard and you
know and you know just and again like
you know and for our listeners like you
know I you know that our desire to have
more of these you know sort of
experiences is there is just you know
again just it's a it's it's very tricky
trying to you know trying to you know be
able to bring in enough people you know
just to find the right opportunities to
do it yeah I mean I I'm sorry I I was
saying this just recently in light of
this very inside baseball but in light
of a certain sweet I will stay straight
up that you know I I think that you know
the most how I feel is at the root of
the problem or a one of the roots of the
problem is that we don't have black and
people of color in decision-making
positions now I'm not saying that we
should be made bosses straight up I'm
not saying that we need to be boss yeah
I'm saying yo I can barely handle my
[ __ ] please don't make me in charge of
other people's [ __ ]
but what I'm what I'm trying to say with
that
is that we see a lot of flake as well
intention as it might be we see messages
[ __ ] up all the time at its core and
people get drags for them and they face
the consequences because because of that
and the root of the problem is that you
don't have people with perspective in
decision-making positions and like I
said I want well I want to be boss but
what I mean by that is that we need to
be in on those conversations we need to
be able to influence how those things
are communicated so y'all don't [ __ ] it
up and you come from a genuine place
rather than being like oh I'm white I
have I'm so ignorant please educate me
like no that's that's you shouldn't be
saying that bro like you should be
proactive in that and we can be the ones
to tell you like don't don't say that
don't say that this is do this first
alright you have this like to think
about this first
and if we're in the room with those
conversations then it would do it would
do them a lot of favors man like I'm 30
second conversation like just be right
hey is this a good idea to do we'll look
at and be like like no or yeah sure you
can probably do that I think the big the
only thing only good can come from
surrounding yourself with unique
perspectives that you don't have
that's the there is no downside to it
you learn and you open your mind up to
different ways of thinking and that
extends to everything like not just
decisions that need to be made or if
you're on a corporate ladder and you're
thinking about whether a tweet should or
shouldn't go out that it doesn't just
benefit that it's you as a gamer we want
to try and make this applicable to our
audience which are people that love
games there's probably things happening
in the games that you play on a day to
day basis you just have no clue about
and by surrounding yourself following
speaking to reading the work of people
who have unique voices that come from
unique perspectives the only thing
you're doing is making yourself smaller
finding new new on
two games that you probably already have
played no love is like whatever maybe
and then improving games as a whole it
the upside of supporting colored people
like people like voices you know non
black people of color voices is
everything gets better everything and
the way you do that is by surrounding
yourself with them and speaking to them
and pushing them forward letting them
lead the way and that's what play for
all is about that's what black lives
matter is about and that's what we want
to support and you can do that in so
many ways you can read Jordan's article
is are calls where there's literature on
how you can educate yourself about the
struggles that black people face and
there's also links there to black
creators everything you need is not
everything but a lot of what you need is
there the springboard is there for you
to jump off or use it and then you can
help you please and and you can go to
bit ly /gs - BLM and donate that's
that's our that's our black lives matter
donation link we're gonna be using it
you know throughout their six weeks you
don't have to use all one if there's
another one go and find it and use it
we're not saying we're not getting
anything out of this ultimately our goal
is to support the cause if you want to
go directly to them and not use our
bitly link all that we're doing is
tracking it through that so we know but
go and just support um the decors
support the movement and trust us like
I'm like Michael said I'm not a person
you know I'm a black I'm not a black
person I'm a person of color same way I
am but everything that Alessandro has
said today everything that Jordan has
said today we all 100% agree with we're
all back and they have been saying
things get better if you support those
voices to do that having said that I
think we're going to end the podcast
here ordinarily we would have a
questions there's no question sections
we do have part we have questions from
the audience and
they're great and they are they've been
sent in through - after that podcast
against but a comment also on our
discord channel and so if you want to
get access hit myself up or I am or Jake
or anyone else that is on the games but
II know we can get you in they they are
of a certain tone though the tone being
there light-hearted some of them they
you know talk about what stuff you like
in outside of games and very much not in
line with the tone of what's happening
right now so I think it is worth pushing
those questions to next week so we can
leave you with the message that you
should support black lives matter
you should read up on the perspectives
that are important and do your best to
educate yourself support those people
and do the same for the people around
you and Jordan where can people find you
on to where they can find me
JM r a.m. ie for basically just a bunch
of stupid anime and apex legend [ __ ] I
am where you are and what you go you
could find me in all of my [ __ ] at
Michael P Higham on Twitter and yet
engage with the things I say or do or
don't cuz I get nervous when people
follow me because I don't be like damn
now I got a it makes me nervous buddy I
appreciate it
but yeah we're follow all of us we're
all doing great work play for all is
poppin off and a lot of people are
putting a lot of time and effort into
those things and just everything on site
like everyone's putting in a lot of good
work so you know sign about me follow
GameSpot and all the people around us
and check out that that article that
Jordan and all of us pitched in to see
check out those perspectives that you
may not have had otherwise Cassandra why
people can can people find you what you
got yeah you can find me on Twitter at a
flurry a fi ll AR I I basically share
some my articles but also the great
articles that from other outlets as well
and uh I should also share a lot of
political stuff so that gets
nerves uh too bad yeah yeah it's like I
said it's important for you know people
to listen to people that you know aren't
like them you know that perspective is
important and you know it's more than
ever especially so yeah yeah we also
have like Michael said we have play for
all happening with our charity event
I've been helping to more schedule some
stuff for that we've got some really
cool stuff happening like next few weeks
so I can tell you it's it's gonna be
pretty dope and yeah I'm looking forward
to the final whatever we're doing with
fantasy whatever in the coming weeks
yes yeah that's it
you can find me on twitter at amore h
and currently working on play for also
please watch and support black lives
matter donate if you can we're also
raising money for healthcare workers
fighting colvett relief and links to
support those or on our sites we will
have regular charity streams every day
and this is a press conference that day
for usually between 12 and 2 PT fun
stuff all going all money going towards
good causes so please watch and we'll
catch you again next week goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]